C'est terrible.
Les dernières années,
nous avons sorti ces bateaux avec ces grands filets
et avons collecté ces bouts de plastique puis les avons observés au microscope.
Nous les avons triés
et avons placé les données sur une carte.
Cela prend du temps et est très cher.
Et il est plutôt risqué de sortir ces gros bateaux.
Avec mes élèves, qui ont entre 6 et 15 ans,
nous rêvons d'inventer une meilleure méthode.
Nous avons transformé notre petite salle de classe à Hong Kong
en un atelier.
Nous avons construit un établi,
à plusieurs hauteurs pour que même les plus petits puissent participer.
Laissez-moi vous dire que les enfants sont géniaux et prudents
avec des outils électriques.
(Rires)
Non, pas vraiment.
De retour au plastique.
Nous collectons ce plastique, le réduisons à la taille qu'il a dans l'océan,
ce qui est très petit car il se casse.
Nous travaillons ainsi.
Je laisse libre cours à l'imagination de mes élèves.
Mon travail est de collecter le meilleur des idées de chacun
et de les combiner en quelque chose qui, je l'espère, fonctionnera.
Nous avons convenu qu'au lieu de collecter des morceaux de plastique,
nous allons collecter les données.
Avec un robot, nous photographions le plastique --
les robots : les enfants sont tout excités.
Ensuite nous faisons ce que nous appelons un « prototypage rapide ».
Nous sommes si rapides à prototyper
qu'il n'est pas encore l'heure de manger que nous avons déjà fini.
(Rires)
Nous transformons des lampes et webcams en accessoires de plomberie
et nous les assemblons pour créer un robot qui flotte et se déplace dans l'eau,
à travers le plastique qu'on y trouve --
voici l'image que nous obtenons du robot.
Nous voyons des morceaux de plastique flottant devant les capteurs.
L'ordinateur de bord traite l'image
et mesure la taille de chaque particule.
Nous avons donc une estimation grossière de la quantité de plastique dans l'eau.
A chaque étape, nous avons documenté cette invention
sur un site d'inventeurs : Instructables,
dans l'espoir que quelqu'un pourrait encore l'améliorer.
Ce que ce projet avait de génial, c'est que les élèves ont vu un problème local
et boum -- ils essayent immédiatement de le régler.
[Je peux creuser mon problème local]
A Hong Kong, mes élèves sont hyper-connectés.
Ils regardent les informations, vont sur internet
et ils sont tombés sur cette image.
Cet enfant, qui ne doit pas avoir 10 ans, nettoyant une marée noire à mains nues,
aux Sundarbans, au Bangladesh, la plus grande forêt de mangrove du monde.
Ils étaient vraiment choqués
parce que c'est l'eau qu'ils boivent, dans laquelle ils se baignent,
dans laquelle ils pêchent -- c'est l'endroit où ils vivent.
Vous pouvez voir que l'eau est marron, la boue et le pétrole sont marron,
donc quand tout est mélangé,
ils est difficile de voir ce qu'il y a dans l'eau.
Il a une technologie, plutôt simple,
du nom de spectrométrie,
permettant de voir ce qu'il y a dans l'au.
Nous avons donc construit un prototype de spectromètre
permettant d'émettre de la lumière dans différentes substances
produisant différents spectres
afin de vous aider à identifier ce qu'il y a dans l'eau.
Nous avons équipé ce prototype d'un capteur
et l'avons envoyé au Bangladesh.
Ce que ce projet a de génial
est que, au-delà de régler un problème local,
ou de considérer un problème local,
mes élèves ont utilisé leur empathie et leur sens créatif
pour aider, à distance, d'autres enfants.
[Je peux creuser un problème lointain]
J'étais donc obligé de faire la deuxième expérience,
et je voulais aller encore plus loin --
peut-être régler un problème plus difficile et qui me touchait plus.
Je suis à moitié Japonais, à moitié Français.
Peut-être vous souvenez-vous du fort tremblement de terre au Japon, en 2011.
Il était si violent qu'il a déclenché plusieurs énormes vagues,
des tsunamis.
Ces tsunamis ont détruit de nombreuses villes de la côte est du Japon.
En un instant, plus de 14 000 personnes sont mortes.
Cela a également endommagé la centrale nucléaire de Fukushima,
qui était au bord de l'eau.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai lu les rapports
et environ 300 tonnes
fuitent de la centrale nucléaire dans l'Océan Pacifique.
Tout l'Océan Pacifique contient des traces de contamination au césium-137.
Si vous allez sur la côte ouest, vous pouvez mesurer Fukushima partout.
Si vous regardez une carte, la majorité de la radioactivité
a été emportée loin des côtes japonaises
et maintenant -- cela semble sûr, c'est bleu.
En réalité, cela est un peu plus compliqué qu'il n'y semble.
Je suis allé à Fukushima tous les ans depuis l'accident.
Je mesure indépendamment et avec d'autres scientifiques,
sur la terre, dans la rivière --
cette fois-ci, nous voulions emmener les enfants.
Bien sûr, nous ne les avons pas emmenés, les parents ont refusé.
(Rires)
Tous les soirs, nous faisions un rapport au « Centre de Commande » --
ils portent des masques différents.
On pourrait croire qu'ils n'ont pas travaillé sérieusement, mais c'est faux
parce qu'ils devront vivre toute leur vie avec la radioactivité.
Ce que nous avons fait avec eux,
c'est de parler des données que nous avions collectées
et décider où nous devrions aller ensuite --
la stratégie, l'itinéraire, etc...
Pour faire cela, nous avons créé une carte topographique approximative
de la région qui entoure la centrale nucléaire.
Nous avons créé une carte numérique,
nous saupoudrions des pigments
pour représenter les données de la radioactivité en temps réel,
nous vaporisions de l'eau pour simuler la pluie.
Ainsi, nous pouvions voir que la poussière radioactive
descendait les montagnes jusqu'à la rivière
puis jusqu'à l'océan.
C'était une approximation.
Mais avec cela en tête, nous avons organisé cette expédition,
qui était la plus proche de la centrale nucléaire jamais faite.
Nous naviguions à 1,5 kilomètres de la centrale nucléaire
et, avec l'aide des pêcheurs locaux,
nous avons collecté des sédiments du fond marin
avec un échantillonneur personnalisé que nous avons inventé et créé.
Nous avons emballé les sédiments dans de petits sacs
et les avons répartis dans des centaines de sacs
que nous avons envoyés à diverses universités.
Nous avons créé une carte de la radioactivité du fond marin,
surtout dans les estuaires où les poissons se reproduisent.
J'espère que nous avons amélioré
la sécurité des pêcheurs et de vos sushis préférés.
(Rires)
Vous pouvez voir une progression,
nous sommes passés d'un problème local à un problème lointain à un problème global.
Travailler à différentes échelles étaient très excitant,
surtout avec des technologies très simples et libres.
C'était également de plus en plus frustrant
parce que nous n'avons que mesuré les dommages que nous avons causés.
Nous n'avons pas commencé à résoudre les problèmes.
Je me demande donc si nous devrions aller de l'avant
et essayer d'inventer de meilleures façons de faire ces choses.
La salle de classe commençait à sembler petite.
Nous avons trouvé un site industriel à Hong Kong
et l'avons transformé en l'espace le plus large
qui soit concentré sur les impacts sociaux et environnementaux.
C'est dans le centre de Hong Kong,
c'est un endroit où nous pouvons travailler le bois, le métal,
faire la chimie, de la biologie, de l'optique.
Nous pouvons presque tout y construire.
C'est un endroit où enfants et adultes peuvent jouer ensemble,
où les rêves des enfants peuvent devenir réalité
grâce à l'aide des adultes
et où les adultes peuvent redevenir enfants.
Élève : Accélération ! Accélération !
Cesar Harada : Nous posons des questions.
pouvons-nous inventer la mobilité future avec des énergies renouvelables ?
Par exemple.
Ou : pouvons-nous améliorer la mobilité des personnes âgées
en transformant des fauteuils roulants standard en des véhicules électriques ?
Le plastique, le pétrole, la radioactivité sont des héritages terribles
mais le pire héritage que nous pouvons laisser à nos enfants, c'est le mensonge.
Nous ne pouvons plus nous permettre de protéger les enfants de l'horrible vérité
parce que, pour inventer les solutions, nous avons besoin de leur imagination.
Citoyens, scientifiques, créateurs, rêveurs --
nous devons préparer la prochaine génération
à qui l'environnement et les gens importent
et qui peut y agir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)